tanja mühling haus verschwindet am 15
oktober
1998 auf dem weg zur schule spurlos 15
jahre ist sie da gerade alt und tanja
taucht nie wieder auf ein
unvorstellbares leid für ihre familie
tanjas eltern erhalten damals noch zwei
mysteriöse briefe und die polizei
vermutet tanja hat diese briefe
tatsächlich selbst verfasst aber
womöglich wurde sie dazu von ihrem
entführer gezwungen frank schneider
berichtet tanja mühling haus ist ein
hübscher teenager die 15 jährige geht
auf ein gymnasium in wuppertal sie ist
ein sportliches mädchen und träumt davon
eines tages tänzerin zu werden seit
einigen wochen hat die 15-jährige einen
festen freund
am 21 oktober
1998 soll sie eigentlich zur schule
gehen aber sie verlässt das elternhaus
und verschwindet spurlos
wir sind hier in wuppertal und hier
verschwand vor genau 23 jahren tanja
mühling haus damals war ich junger
reporter und habe diesen fall damals
schon verfolgt
man hört dass immer spurlos verschwinden
aber man kann es sich nicht vorstellen
ist fällig der tag sie ging zur
bushaltestelle und plötzlich war sie
einfach weg ist
tanja ausgerissen wurde sie entführt
oder getötet
fragen die ihre mutter seit 23 jahren
quellen tanjas vater ist mittlerweile
verstorben
der tag an dem tanja verschwand da hatte
ich schon so ein komisches gefühl im
bauch
tanja das dauert lange bis ich dich
wiedersehen 20 bis 30 jahre wenn
überhaupt diese intuition die hatte ich
witzigerweise sofort
was hat es mit zwei mysteriösen briefen
auf sich die wenige tage nach tanjas
verschwinden ohne absender auftauchen
stammen sie wirklich von ihr
und welche rolle spielt der verurteilte
straftäter patrick der nach jahren
plötzlich bei der polizei aus sagt er
kenne tanja stimmen seiner angaben
[Musik]
jeder ermittler hat so seinen fall der
in ganz besonders geprägt hat
das leid die trauer die ungewissheit da
kann man auch nicht einfach abschalten
und auch als ermittler fragt man sich
habe ich vielleicht irgendwann mal eine
spur
übersehen oder
falsch bewertet der kriminalfall tanja
mühling haus bewegt die menschen in nrw
heute noch auch bild reporter frank
schneider
von anfang an schreibt er über den fall
die bild zeitung berichtete damals
ausführlich über das verschwinden
hier in wuppertal oberbarmen wohnte
damals tanja mühling haus mit ihren
eltern und auf dieser straße gingen sie
morgens kurz nach halb neun zur schule
was dann wirklich genau passierte weiß
keiner sicher ist nur sie telefonierte
noch mit ihrer mutter aus dem haus um 8
das ist das letzte lebenszeichen von
tanja nur 300 meter geht die 15 jährige
von ihrem zuhause wie sie die
bushaltestelle erreicht von der aus sie
zum carl duisberg gymnasium drei
kilometer weiter fährt
ob sie sich aber überhaupt auf ihren
normalen schulweg gemacht hat bleibt
ungeklärt klar ist nur sie ist dort nie
angekommen
[Musik]
tanja ist ein fröhliches und willens
starkes junges mädchen obwohl in der
pubertät ist sie immer verlässlich warum
sollte sie ausreißen
polizeipräsidium wuppertal
bild reporter frank schneider trifft den
damaligen ermittler alexander kresta mit
ihm rekonstruieren wir diesen
ungeklärten fall wir haben auch keinen
einzigen zeugen gefunden der
letztendlich tanja auf dem schulweg oder
im bus oder noch im bereich der schule
gesehen hat also eigentlich verliert
sich die spur
spätestens im elternhaus warum ist tanja
spurlos verschwunden ist die
gymnasiastin von zu hause weggelaufen
ohne geld kleidung oder papiere oder
wird sie entführt man kann natürlich
auch mutmaßen dass tanja vielleicht
zunächst freiwillig mit jemanden
unbekannten mit gegangen ist oder ist
man ja von vornherein leicht einem
kapitaldelikt zum opfer gefallen ist was
ist mit tanja passiert ihre mutter
erinnert sich an die ersten minuten nach
ihrem verschwinden gegen halb fünf rief
dann ihre schulfreundin an und er fragte
wie es denn der kranken tanja agiert und
da habe ich gesagt ja wieso denn krank
ja sie war doch nicht in der schule ja
und da kam dann der deko klos im magen
noch am selben abend gehen die eltern
zur polizei
natürlich gedanken dass ich sie dann
wirklich irgend vor meinen augen dann
irgendwie gefesselt und geknebelt in
irgendeinem kofferraum gesehen habe
die polizei nimmt die vermisstenanzeige
auf ein routinevorgang dass teenager
fortlaufend passiert häufig dass sie
verschwunden bleiben ist selten
im ersten angriff war dieser fall jetzt
sage ich mal nichts besonderes wir haben
mehr als 1000 vermisstenfälle damals in
der kreispolizeibehörde wuppertal gehabt
davon sind natürlich unheimlich viele
streuner tanja war einer der fälle wo
man sagt okay ist also im elternhaus
abgehauen wenn wir davon ausgehen dass
sie sich selber da entfernt hat und dann
sind tatsächlich auch davon ausgegangen
dass sie nach kurzer zeit wieder nach
hause zurückkehren zwei tage später
scheint es eine erklärung für ihr
verschwinden zu geben ein brief taucht
auf von tanja ohne absender im ersten
brief da hat sie geschrieben bliebe man
lieber papa macht euch keine zu großen
sorgen ich bin gesund und werde in zwei
bis drei wochen wieder zu hause sein
deshalb braucht ihr mich nichts zu
suchen kümmert euch bitte um die hasen
und um das babysitten behaltet bitte die
sache nicht bestellt habe lasst euch für
die zeit was für die schule einfallen
ich brauche ein bisschen abstand und
werde mich nächste woche noch einmal
melden eure tanja die erste resonanz war
gott sei dank sie lebt ist also nicht
irgendwo
tod ins auto gezerrt worden oder so
das war erstmal eine erleichterung
drei tage später schreibst du dann ihr
braucht euch immer noch immer keine
sorgen zu machen mir geht es gut und ich
werde nun doch schon am nächsten
wochenende nach hause kommt deshalb
braucht er mich nicht suchen ich hoffe
ihr habt oder werdet die sachen
erledigen um die ich euch im letzten
brief gebeten habe die briefe sind im
fall eines der zentralen themen muss ich
dazu sagen weil die brief dass ich von
vielen vielen anderen vermisstenfällen
natürlich unterscheiden sind das
wirklich noch die original sämtliche
originalbriefe hier erkennt man auch
tatsächlich dass sie einmal
spurentechnisch behandelt worden sind
und tatsächlich
tanjas dna wird auf den briefumschlägen
nachgewiesen und auch ein schrift
vergleich ergibt die briefe kommen von
ihm
ja auch wenn man es jetzt hier sieht das
ist ja sehr identisch auch die
unterschrift wenn man sieht eure tanja
das sieht man ja eigentlich schon dass
es von einer derselben person
geschrieben wurde ja genau was man nicht
so 100 prozent bewerten kann was euch da
auch mal formuliert worden ist es sind
diese briefe unter druck geschrieben
worden
andere briefe die sie schreibt schreibt
sie tatsächlich viel ausführlicher nicht
in kurzen sätzen sondern in langen
schachtelsätzen mit anderen vokabular
wurde die 15 jährige gezwungen die
briefe zu schreiben wollte ein möglicher
täter zeit gewinnen
als die briefe bei den eltern angekommen
sind waren wir ja auch zunächst
erleichtert und die eltern auch und auch
die eltern sagten naja wir glauben schon
dass sie jetzt wieder kommen wir haben
das auch vermutet wir haben 20 all
unsere maßnahmen eingestellt aber
natürlich ist das ermittlungs niveau zu
diesem zeitpunkt dann etwas gesucht
doch als das wochenende von tanjas
angekündigte rückkehr kommt wartet
mutter elisabeth vergebens ich habe den
ganzen tag die haustür hypnotisiert weil
wir eben gerechnet hatten dass sie kommt
und als sie dann nicht kam da haben wir
dann immer die ganze maschinerie
angeworfen
die gymnasiastin ist seit über zwei
wochen verschwunden einige zeugen melden
sich wollen sie im kölner rotlichtmilieu
gesehen haben bei vermissten sachen wird
generell das rotlichtmilieu wenn man es
jetzt mal so nennen wollen immer gerne
ins feld geführt wenn man sagt wenn sich
personen aus dem lebensumfeld entfernt
haben sind geldmittel nötig da muss man
aber sagen es ist ein extremes risiko
mit 15 jährige die aus einem behüteten
elternhaus kommt in irgendeiner art und
weise in diesem bereich anzubieten und
da sind mir jetzt nicht gerade viele
fälle bekannt
mutter elisabeth wendet sich in ihrer
verzweiflung an die medien
hier war zu der zeit auch wirklich jedes
format recht jeder sender und wir können
dieses bild in die kamera zeigen wir
wollten damit das so viel wie möglich
aufmerksam werden wo ist tanja mühling
haus seit dem 21 oktober 98 ist die
damals 15 jährige verschwunden die
einzige spur zwei briefe in denen sie
ihre rückkehr ankündigt aber sie kommt
nicht wurde sie entführt getötet oder
ist sie weggelaufen jahre lang arbeiten
die ermittler an dem fall dann 16 jahre
nach tanjas verschwinden führt eine spur
zu patrick er behauptet tanja aus einer
drückerkolonne zu kennen
er sagte tanja hätten zusammen mit einer
drückerkolonne gearbeitet aber an
schaffen hätte sie wohl auch gewusst die
hinweise von patrick o führen die
ermittler in ein abgelegenes waldstück
hier soll tanya noch schlimmeres
passiert seien dramatisch klingt
zumindest der hinweis er wäre mit tanja
in einer drückerkolonne gewesen und dann
hätte man beide zwangsweise in einen
wald geführt und in diesem wald anja
angeschossen oder erschossen
wir haben dann natürlich ausführlich
nach spuren gesucht obwohl wir diesen
hinweis von anfang an nicht ernst
genommen haben hätte dieser hinweis
gestimmt was hätte man denn finden
müssen naja das fängt schon mal an damit
dass man auf diesem engen begrenzten uns
beschriebenen waldstück hätte
zerbrochene stücke finden müssen aber
natürlich auch irgendwie spurenträger wo
vielleicht eine dna von tanja zu finden
gewesen wäre letztendlich aber auch blut
oder spuren wo gegraben ist all diese
dinge haben wir nicht gefunden also es
hat sich in den kennzeichnung weise von
einer objektiven lage bestätigt dass ein
solches szenarium wald stattgefunden
die spur wird fallen gelassen
patrick o taucht ab meldet sich aber
2017 drei jahre später wieder diesmal
aus der jva wolfenbüttel wo er wegen
betruges und schwerer körperverletzung
sitzt mutter elisabeth lässt sich auf
ein treffen mit ihm ein das von einem
tv-sender begleitet wird patrick o macht
ein unglaubliches geständnis tanja habe
den schuss überlebt ein gemeinsames kind
mit ihm und wohne unter neuem namen in
frankfurt er will einen kontakt
herstellen
[Musik]
und vertrieb
glaube ich auch
dass sie positiv gelaufen ist und so
weiter weil das waren sich es bedenken
dass da eher vorwurfs mäßig oder so aber
der tag des wiedersehens kommt nicht
elisabeth wird enttäuscht sie wird opfer
eines betrügers der sich alles
ausgedacht hat die ganzen briefe die hin
und her gegangen sind die habe ich alle
auffahrt aber die sind jetzt nicht
sichtbar in meinem keller gut verstaut
weil ich die nie wieder sehen will dass
angehörige von betrügern getäuscht
werden ist bei vermisstenfällen leider
keine seltenheit letztendlich wollen sie
sich ja an diesen einen strohhalm der
möglicherweise die lösung dass die
wiederkehr des kindes bewerten können
wollen sie sich auch klammern und dass
es dann auch für uns als polizei immer
sehr sehr schwierig zu händeln bei
manchen sachen das ist einfach quatsch
das sind hirngespinste
und auch gegen solche leute das muss
mich aussage als polizei gehen wir dann
aber auch strafrechtlich vor eine spur
ins nichts tanja mühling haus bleibt
verschollen sie wird zum cold case
[Musik]
aber wo ist die 15-jährige geblieben wie
kann ein teenager spurlos verschwinden
lebt sie vielleicht noch tanja ist in
jedem tag in meinen gedanken präsent ich
vermisse sie genauso wie vor 23 jahren
das gefühl dass sie lebt das kann man
eigentlich nicht beschreiben das ist
einfach da aber ich habe nicht das
gefühl dass sie tot ist
heute 23 jahre nach tanjas verschwinden
sucht macht ermittler markus lindner
nach neuen ansätzen er hat den fall von
alexander christa übernommen wir suchen
parallelen zu möglicherweise anderen
vermisstenfällen im umkreis von
nordrhein westfalen aber auch über
nordrhein westfalen hinaus wir gucken
nach verurteilten täter nach
sexualtätern nach tätern von
tötungsdelikten und versuchen da einen
vergleich zu finden oder möglicherweise
eine ähnlichkeit die damals mit tanja
mühlhaus oder einstellen
markus lindner bittet die bevölkerung um
hinweise wem ist etwas aufgefallen
an tanjas wohnung im hacken nummer 18
oder auf ihrem weg zur haltestelle
ottenstein in wuppertal
wer hat sie auf dem weg zu ihrer schule
beobachtet
wer hat sie im kölner rotlichtmilieu
erkannt wer hat die 15 jährige tanja
gesehen sie trug eine dunkle jeans und
eine schwarze lederjacke
[Musik]
die ermittler
die familie
und die bild redaktion
sie alle geben nicht auf wollen endlich
gewissheit ich würde mir wünschen noch
mal über den falter in der mitte und ost
zu berichten aber ganz anders als bisher
nämlich dass es ihr gut geht dass sie
lebt dass ich im idealfall ihr gegenüber
sitzt und sie fragen kann warum sie
verschwunden das was in der zeit
passiert ist und vielleicht sogar mit
ansehen durfte dass sie ihre mutter
wieder in die arme nimmt oder die mutter
sie die wird ja wenn du mich hörst sie
ist ich würde mich unwahrscheinlich
freuen wenn wir zwei noch mal zusammen
sprechen könnten bitte melde dich doch
du brauchst dich für nichts zu schämen
lebt anja noch wer kann etwas zur
aufklärung beitragen helfen sie den fall
tanja mühling haus zu lösen
hinweise an die polizei wuppertal unter
284 0
[Musik]